[Music]
oh great you are back what a relief i
trust that you're responsible right you
know mask six feet treat everything you
touch as if it's raw chicken
yeah
it's pretty scary out there though huh
how do we even get to this point it
seems like it was just a few weeks ago
when we didn't even know to take this
whole thing seriously i'm hanging up
calendars rain for this exact purpose oh
it's because it has only been a few
weeks could you keep it down right
well listen there are dozens of reasons
why this has snowballed into a global
pandemic but i'm not really qualified to
talk about most of them
but there is something i can talk about
if you're up for it
it's exponential growth it is really
really hard for human beings to
understand exponential growth most
people
don't understand what an exponential is
when you say something's expanding
exponentially so you take 100 you get a
thousand you get 10 000. our intuition
isn't really capable of understanding
exponential growth and the irony is that
it's actually fairly easy to understand
on paper it's not hard math i mean it's
no factor calculus or differential
equations or taxes
it's just raising a number like 2 to the
power of another number you know squared
cubed two to the power of four
we rarely have need for exponents larger
than this so what if we raise two to the
power of one hundred
here is a classic sheet of paper nothing
remarkable about it if i was to double
this i'd have two sheets of paper if i
was to double this again i'd have four
again and i'd have eight so on and so
forth you get the idea so what if i
doubled this a hundred times how thick
would that stack of paper be don't
calculate the answer what does your gut
tell you we go straight from the gut old
school quarter crew fans might recognize
when i asked my coworkers this exact
question 10 10 to 15 feet probably is
what i was going to eventually get to i
don't know probably like three of these
buildings 200 200 feet 200 feet okay
probably like a freaking the distance of
the state of texas or something
outrageous
that is pretty dang outrageous
[Music]
500 meters 500 meters yeah okay here's a
hint
how far into outer space will it go oh
my god at 10 doublings the stack of
paper would be 10 centimeters tall but
just five doublings later you wouldn't
be able to stack it in your house at 20
doublings the stack of paper would
stretch across an entire soccer pitch at
30 doublings it would officially reach
outer space stretching over a hundred
kilometers straight up to get to the
moon we would just need 12 more
doublings on top of that so what about a
hundred doublings i bet you're prepared
for a pretty large number but trust me
you're really not this stack would be so
tall the only way to measure it would be
in light years
13
billion
light years i said 500 meters man the
thing about exponential growth is that
most of the growth happens at the last
moment it's what gives graphs like this
that hockey stick look and in the case
of doublings literally half of the total
amount was gained at the final step no
matter which step you're on
in fact at this virus's current rate of
spread in the next four months it will
have infected one trillion people wait a
minute
okay okay so technically the spread of
this virus actually follows what's
called a logistic curve as more people
use social distancing or die there are
fewer people the virus can infect and
the rate of infection begins to decrease
this is called the inflection point and
is the peak of the curves we're trying
to flatten right now but this still
doesn't explain why most people are
surprised by how fast this pandemic is
spreading so here's a final example the
grand canyon is the largest canyon on
the planet it's 277 miles long and has a
volume of a thousand cubic miles you
could pour every single river on earth
into the grand canyon and still only
fill half of it a water droplet on the
other hand contains .05 milliliters of
water a minuscule amount but in this
example as every minute that goes by
this droplet doubles in size two drops
four drops eight i'm sure you've caught
on by now that it'll eventually fill up
the entire canyon and you'd be right but
how long will that take
imagine this you're finishing up a hike
down in the grand canyon you get word
that 20 minutes ago a magic drop of
water started doubling its size every
single minute that's weird even your
grandpa's never heard of that happening
in his entire life but in the 20 minutes
since it started it's only gotten to the
size of a couple jugs of water um okay
you shrug and move on with your hike
another 15 minutes go by when you get a
warning alert on your phone the park is
now an emergency lockdown and everyone
has to evacuate immediately the water
has now reached the size of an olympic
swimming pool you are already heading
back to your car but this is ridiculous
what kind of a danger does a swimming
pool represent have they forgotten that
you're in the grand canyon sure i mean
if you hurried you can get out quicker
but it's a nice day out and what about
your freedom finally an hour has gone by
since the water droplet began to double
and you finally notice it you're nearing
the top of the canyon but you can see it
way down there at the bottom at the 60
minute mark the water droplet has now
overtaken the volume of the colorado
river literal alarms are now blaring
everyone's panicking people are being
airlifted to safety but they don't have
room for you it took an hour for the
water to reach a point where you could
finally see it how much more time until
the water fills the entire canyon the
answer
six minutes
you've now run out of time to escape
now obviously this is an absurd scenario
but you could probably see the parallels
with the spread of the current pandemic
fortunately it is not as bad as my
examples might make it seem however it
is indeed proving to be a world-changing
event that not enough people took
seriously soon enough perhaps now you
understand the importance of the
unprecedented measures currently locking
down society you see it was never going
to seem like it was that bad until it
was
it's really hard to say where we'll be
in the near future are we nearing an
inflection point and things will start
going back to normal soon or are we
sitting in a canyon watching the water
level slowly rise i wish i could answer
that but i can't
the only way we'll beat this is by
stepping up individually be responsible
and even though we're all apart we'll
make it through this together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you